donc ce marchand de chemise était
exactement l'emplacement de la bouche et
une rétrospective en images des
commerçants d'antan notamment d'avant
guerre c'est ce que propose l'union des
commerçants et artisans de poissy
objectif animer les rues sans photos ont
été exposées en vitrine des boutiques
des clichés prêté par un collectionneur
locale on a fait un choix à trois
personnes deux photos chez un
collectionneur locale qui a une pression
de plus de 1000 cartes postales et
photos des époques avant guerre et après
guerre donc il a fait le prêt de ses
photos des photos qui ont été proposées
à 100 commerçants de poissy certaines
ont été positionnés à leur emplacement
exact mais on arrive pour pour
exactement trente huit commerces à
retrouver exactement
et on a même retrouvé des des grands
pères qui ont connu on les a en enfant
sur la photo en petit enfant d'ailleurs
de 6 ans on les a sur la photo ils sont
devenus grands pères dans l'ain qui a
été sur la photo il a exactement 96 ans
actuellement les affiches sont
disponibles à la vente une expérience
qui devrait être renouvelée l'année
prochaine avec des clichés des commerces
d'après guerre